εσείς γράθεται πλσε γράφο έγραφα κιγράφο αλλά φυσικά πρέπει ναα σας πό ότι οι υπίς
θεριαρκετό χρόνο δεν έχω πολύ χρόνο ήμου να πάντοταιαγαπούς αδιλογο δεχνία από παιδί είχα διαβάσει
κλασικούς όλου εδό τους κλασικούς όταν ήμοναστο υνάσιο ήμουνα ο παδόςς θερμός το μύρου α
στη τρί τητάει το γιμνασί θα μεταφράσει δυόραψοδίες τις οποίες δυστυχός έχω χάσει μαζί με
πολλάλλα πράγματα ο πολιτισμός ιαμένα θυσεα είναι το μεγαλύτερο ερίσμα της κύπρου η κύπρος θα
έπρεπε να εξοδέψει κέλεφτα αλλά να σχολιηθεί όσο γίνεται περισσότερο με τον πολιτισμό δεν πρέπει
η κύπρος να σημαίνει κακά πράγματα που μας έχουν φορτώσει ξερογ ξέπλημα χρήματος το ένατι
το άλλο έχουμε ένα πολιτισμό πολύ παλιό αρχαίο μεδική μας γραφεί με το κυπριακό συλαβάριο
με πάρα πολλά παρα πολλαβρήματα αρχαιολογικά θύμαμε με το βάσο το καραγιόργι συμεργάστικά πάλι στο
ρισητούτο κύπρου ια να καταγράψουμε κυπριακά εκτός κύπρου ο βάσος ο καραγιόγης έρες που δέος
άνθρωπος που δέως αρχαιολόγος των αγαπούσαμε σε